I also am continuing to keep you posted
on the president's frequent golfing
escapades on Sunday during yet another
trip to Florida where Trump couldn't be
bothered to leave even when bombing a
foreign country Trump played his 17th
game of golf in 12 weeks as president
Trump played golf on Saturday and on
Sunday the Trump White House has
declined to comment on what else Trump
was doing at Trump International Golf
Course this weekend so that's probably
the only thing he was doing playing golf
since the White House I would assume
would jump on an opportunity to tell the
public he was doing something other than
just playing golf Trump is very
consistent he's averaging about a game
and a half of golf per week or roughly
three games every two weeks the average
person with a full-time job Pat would
consider themselves too busy to play
three rounds of golf every two weeks and
somehow the President of the United
States is able to do it yeah maybe you
can do it every Saturday or something
like that but when you have more rounds
of golf to log than actual weeks as
president and that's the problem oh it's
a major problem and not to get too
conspiratorial but the White House has
twice been caught lying about the
frequency of Trump's golfing so these 17
games of golf are the ones we found out
about there could well be many more that
though I mean I know the White House is
pretty incompetent but at least I'm open
to the idea that they've successfully
covered up other games of golf exceeding
the number 17 I'll remind you that
Donald Trump relentlessly mocked
President Obama for his golf playing
President Obama waited he had the
decency to wait more than three months
before playing his first game of golf as
president and on average he played
obviously way less golf and Trump but
given the events of the past week how
sadly ironic are some of Donald Trump's
tweets about this and also Sean
Hannity's Sean Hannity once tweeting
glad our arrogant president is enjoying
his taxpayer-funded golf outing after
announcing the u.s. should take military
action against Syria what does that
remind us of all right Trump enjoying
his taxpayer-funded golf outing after
announcing and
taking military action against Syria and
then also from Donald Trump's Twitter
account in 2013 President Obama is not
busy talking to Congress about Syria
he is playing golf go figure a new
report says that trumps weekly vacations
have already cost taxpayers more than
what two years of Obama vacations cost
fiscal conservatism huh and I think it's
the hypocrisy that makes this a real
story because otherwise it would be sort
of trivial people could argue well he's
still doing work while he's playing golf
he's meeting with other officials
shoring dignitaries or maybe he just
needs to relax but when you have tweets
in the past few years about criticizing
your predecessor for doing the exact
same thing it's much worse not only that
when you campaign on the fact that you
want vacation not only that when you
campaign on fiscal conservatism and
Trump's vacations would end up costing
taxpayers around six hundred million
dollars over four years which happens to
be about the amount that Trump wants to
cut from the federal budget and this
isn't even touching the million a week
that it cost to keep Melania Trump and
Baron Trump at Trump Tower
you might remember Trump said at a
campaign event last year quote I don't
ever think that I'd see anything I just
want to stay in the White House and work
my ass off make great deals right who's
gonna leave I mean who's gonna leave
Trump is gonna leave he spent more than
a quarter of his time as president at
Murrow logo I guess to be fair Trump's
not getting paid but that's not actually
true Trump is getting paid what he
chooses to do with the money after being
paid is his business
trumpets can't be okay with this right I
mean we're talking about lying breaking
campaign promises and being the opposite
of fiscally conservative and being a
total hypocrite based on his criticisms
of Obama well with every politician
there's going to be some broken promises
right but I think he just takes it to
another level yeah whenever he takes a
position on something you can point to
something he said even a year before and
it's the exact opposite and that's with
everything every absolutely oh and
weather and and a lot of people say
David you know I don't care about golf
okay you don't have to care about golf
but you must care about the hypocrisy
the lying
the cost and and the broken promises
right I mean you you must care about
that if you're evaluating this president
based on what he said he would do and
what he's actually doing there are many
people on our reddit discussion forum
talking about this and many other
stories you can join at david pakman.com
slash read it joined the conversation a
lot of conversation happening there
every single day today's episode of the
david pakman show is made possible in
part by Warby Parker eyeglasses Warby
Parker recently did the right thing and
ditched advertising on right-wing
conspiracy website Breitbart pulling
their ads off and you can get the free
five-day home Tryon from Warby Parker
check out their glasses I use them when
I'm not wearing contact lenses I started
with the free at-home trial they send
you five pairs of glasses you see which
ones you like you send them back and
whichever one you pick they will put
your prescription in - I like this
because I can actually show the glasses
to other people and not have to just
decide on the spot like in an eyeglass
store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
costs that including lenses and for
every pair sold they give a pair to
someone in need so to try the five pairs
and support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS